la réduction de la transmission de
lakovic 19 dans les écoles passe pour
plusieurs par une meilleure ventilation
des classes mais les moyens à prendre
pour y arriver ne faut pas toujours
l'unanimité certains frottis l'école
[Musique]
pour ces étudiants du collège de
montréal
c'est une journée comme les autres mais
en réalité ce qui est complètement
changé depuis quelques semaines c'est la
qualité de l'air qu'on respire dans leur
classe alors ce qui est arrivé c'est que
on a installé des systèmes de
ventilation individuel dans chacune des
classes qui ont la même fonction que le
système de ventilation centrale et ça ne
semble pas avoir été si compliqué
rien de plus facile que de filtrer de
ventoline classe dans une école au
québec
[Musique]
depuis la rentrée l'automne dernier la
question de la ventilation dans les
écoles fait la manchette au fil des mois
les avis scientifiques sur la
probabilité que le corps annabi russe se
propage dans l'air se sont multipliés
alors que les écoles se remplissait
comme l'ont sans doute fin d'autres
directeurs et directrices d'école
patrice est eh ben c'est poser la
question dès le mois d'août que fait on
à la moitié des classes dont les locaux
pour les élèves qui étaient et ventilés
mécaniquement par un système de
ventilation centrale et l'autre moitié
c'est à dire 25 ans qui eux c'est la
ventilation se fait par l'ouverture des
fenêtres la moitié des écoles au québec
n'ont pas de système de ventilation
mécanique ouvrir fréquemment les
fenêtres par temps froid pour ventiler
les classes n'est pas toujours simple
pratique et installer un système de
ventilation centrale est parfois
complexe à cause de l' architecture ou
de l'âge du bâtiment
celui-ci à 150 ans alors on a opté pour
des petits systèmes de ventilation
individuel dans chacune des classes
[Musique]
l'installation des systèmes dans les 27
classes a été réalisé par le personnel
en interne en deux semaines durant
congés de noël ou retour en janvier
tout était en match
[Musique]
mais avant d'aller plus loin on peut
comprendre ce qu'ils biais de la bonne
ventilation dans une classe quand on
veut réduire la propagation de virus
il y a le niveau de co2 la quantité
d'aérosols de particules en suspension
et la dispersion de l'air ou le flux
d'air dans la pièce
le niveau de dioxyde de carbone le co2
dans une classe en début de journée
correspond en général au niveau de co2
contenu dans l'air extérieur plus ou
moins 400 parties par million 400 tpm
au fur et à mesure que les étudiants
s'installent le co2 qu'ils expirent fait
monter sa concentration à quel rythme
cela dépend de la taille de la pièce du
nombre d'occupants et de ce qu'ils font
règle générale on vise un niveau de co2
autour de 1000 ppm pour assurer le
confort des élèves
un mot sur la qualité de l'air en
janvier le ministre de l'éducation du
québec fait le bilan des relevés de co2
dans près de 1400 classe au québec et
l'échantillonnage qu'on a fait nous
arrive avec un taux moyen de 800 4 ppm
donc 20 pour cent de mieux que les
limites qu'on a qui est déjà très
exigeant dans chaque classe on a pris
trois mesures de co2 une au début et au
milieu du court puis à la fin après
l'ouverture de fenêtres pendant 20
minutes une méthodologie contesté par
plusieurs juges et peut toujours
représentative de ce qui se passe en
temps normal dans les classes
[Musique]
licata les post doctorant au département
de génie du bâtiment à l'université
concordia dans le cadre d'un projet de
recherche dans les écoles de montréal
son groupe à mesurer en continu le taux
de co2 dans certaines classes jazz band
parmi les mesures il aussi ou de à un
moment de la journée n'est pas suffisant
ça peut être une période où les niveaux
sont faibles ça ne décrit pas la réalité
complète d'une classe pour obtenir des
mesures plus significative
on privilégie souvent un échantillonnage
en continu toute la journée durant
plusieurs jours à différents endroits
dans la classe dans les classes où on
prenait des mesures ça se faisait toutes
les cinq minutes
donc on voyait clairement les tendances
et le moment où ces ateliers son
excellence monsieur deux ans que c'est
comme enola tu sais tu sais on a un
mauvais des grandes concentrations de
co2 on peut dire qu'on n'a pas assez de
25 ans on n'a pas assez de reporter
frais c'est tout ce qu'il soit dit mais
ça derrière par rapport à la présence
d'autres contaminants
c'est vrai on présume que si le co2
s'accumulent les chances sont bonnes que
les contaminants s'accumulent aussi y
compris des aérosols contenant des virus
mais ce n'est pas une preuve directe
pour éviter que le co2 comme les
contaminants s'accumulent
on les dit lui en faisant entrer de
l'air frais de l'extérieur
tout l'air de la classe est toujours
recirculer mais filtré nous ouvrons la
fenêtre régis bottes et régisseur de
bâtiments au collège de montréal
nous allons chercher de l'air extérieur
la fenêtre extérieur est ouverte que
nous aspirons qui passent dans
l'équipement à l'intérieur vous avez un
filtre hepa qui filtre l'air extérieur
et que nous rediffusons par
l'intermédiaire de cette gaine lui son
équipe ont vu à toute l'installation du
système dans l'école et donc la comète
602,2 système par classe un système qui
lui va apporter 100 % de l'air frais
filtré en provenance de l'extérieur puis
un autre système qui va utiliser un
ratio d'à peu près 55 ans dont 50 %
d'air frais et 50 % de reçus les
le principe consiste à réaliser un
apport d'air frais équivalent à la
quantité de co2 générées dans la classe
donc si on utilise un compteur de
particules au laser simon est vrai que
le fabricant de ce système qui le
distribue partout dans le monde
un système très simple une soufflerie un
filtre est pas comme dans les avions et
les grands hôpitaux et un pré filtre au
charbon
ici en fait on fait une filtration
complète donc on va filtrer l'air à
toutes les 10 minutes donc six fois à
l'heure au pardon qu'at-il six fois donc
ici ils ont décidé d'aller vraiment au
maximum
maintenant est-ce que des appareils de
filtration portatif combiné à
l'ouverture fréquente des venets
permettent d'atteindre les mêmes
résultats
une équipe dirigée par yann courte us de
l'université goethe à francfort en
allemagne a testé ces appareils de
purification d'air constitue à sion réel
quatre appareils avec des filtres hepa
disposés dans une classe équivalent au
nôtre en terme de dimensions et
d'occupation on a découvert qu'il était
efficace pour réduire la quantité
d'aérosols peu importe leur taille et
90% de ces particules étaient retirés de
l'air en 30 minutes
malgré tout au québec le ministère de
l'éducation a émis des réserves quant à
l'utilisation de ces appareils mobiles
de filtration de l'air le groupe
d'experts ne recommande pas
l'utilisation de ces politiques à
tordères à l'intérieur des classes dans
l'école on craint que les appareils
portatifs n'arrive pas à faire leur
travail de filtration s'ils sont trop
loin de la source d'émission du virus ou
trop peu nombreux pour filtrer tout le
volume d'air de la classe
halima lui fait partie du groupe
d'experts qui a conseillé le
gouvernement québécois
même si on essaie d'augmenter
l'aspiration très fort ça va être très
difficile d'aller chercher d entraide
très loin et donc revoir purifiée
jusqu'à proches dans le voisinage de de
purificateur et on a un risque de
générer des flux d'air très important ce
qu'on veut pas faire
au collège de montréal l'air frais et
recirculer est diffusée dans la partie
supérieure de la pièce les refile trees
se mélange à l'air chaud qui s'y
accumulent avant de se disperser
lentement dans la classe c'est pas le
cas pour les équipements portatifs c'est
que le flux d'air et les east concentré
de saison il va être redoutable
la crainte c'est que le flux d'air
filtrés par l'appareil transporte le
virus d'une personne potentiellement
infectées vers une autre qui ne l'est
pas
le rôle le plus important de ces
appareils est de réduire le niveau moyen
d'aérosols la perturbation du fus terre
est un problème que je dirais mineur
parce que prévoir avec précision
l'écoulement de l'air et la position de
personnes affectées est impossible ceci
dit on doit se rappeler que l'appareil
mobile filtre les poussières et les airs
au sol mais pas le co2 il faut quand
même avoir un apport d'air frais pour 10
lui le co2
peu importe le système de ventilation de
filtration le risque de contamination
par contact direct ou par gouttelettes
lui demain à l'heure du lunch par
exemple quand les masques sont enlevées
tout la difficulté d'établir dans quelle
proportion la ventilation réduit le
risque de contamination
et si le coût de l'équipement en vaut le
jeu pour patricia steben le choix est
clair en termes de coûts ces 2500 $ par
classe et inclut les équipements et les
gaines qui sont installés au final tu es
à l'équipement c'est un investissement
parce qu'après la pandémie je pense que
d'avoir un taux de co2 adéquat d'avoir
une filtration des particules qui
viennent de l'extérieur
ce ne sont pas juste c'est positif là
alors on ce système qu'on va conserver
après le repos retiré après la fin de la
pandémie
avec l'arrivée du printemps et la
possibilité d'ouvrir les fenêtres plus
souvent et plus longtemps les écoles mal
ventilée pourront souffler un peu mais
avec cette menace des variants qui plane
au dessus nous parions que certaines
écoles pourrait respirer plus tranquille
que d'autres
[Musique]